hey guys it is birthday yep done stop
this
[Music]
first up get excited part of exile fans
yet another expansion is headed your way
before the years out our 2013 PC game of
the year winner is getting itself an
expansion called war of the atlas which
will arrive on PC and Xbox one on
December 8 the game also just got its
full of a riot expansion earlier this
year the expansion is largely adding
content for existing players but there
is also the addition of four new
necromancy themed skill gems and six new
support gems there's also a brand new
story branch where you get to choose to
fight against the forces of either the
Elder or the shaper 32 new randomized
maps in the endgame new endgame
equipment and unique items as well as
the abyss challenge League an arena to
battle a new class of food that appears
while playing through the game for more
details on this expansion head to our
story on GameSpot got one now until the
release of Dragon Ball fighters when you
can finally kick the [ __ ] out of Fraser
come with a companion cold fridge
terrible terrible the roster of the game
continues to grow as three new
characters have been announced in the
latest issue of Japanese magazine v-jump
it was revealed that adult Gohan go
tanks and Kidd booth are all playable in
the fighting game that's nearly
indiscernible from the source material
adult Gohan special is the ultimate
Kamehameha the fused form of trunks and
goten can use his charging ultra booboo
volleyball and super ghost kamikaze
attacks and margin boos final form Kid
Buu has tricky attacks thanks to his
elastic body free jump also revealed the
in-game shop and arcade mode while
playing you'll earns any that you can
then use to purchase titles and
different character colors from the shop
while Arcade Mode throws you into a
predetermined amount of battles where
your path through is dependent on if you
win all those Dragon Ball fighters is
out in the West on January 26th on ps4
Xbox one and PC those of you who
pre-order will get access to the game's
upcoming beta just when you thought
you'd heard everything you needed to
hear about loot boxes along comes
Belgium
Belgians gaming Authority is
investigating whether or not loot boxes
like those found in overwatch and
battlefront 2 should be classified at
gambling in Belgium games a chance
require a special permit if the game's
random reward system is found to be
gambling Blizzard and EA could have to
pay a fine amounting to quote hundreds
of thousands of euros and the games
could be removed from sale in Belgium
this isn't the first we've heard about
loot boxes being considered gambling
earlier this year the ESRB in the US
concluded that loot boxes do not
constitute gambling a spokesperson told
Kotaku well there's an element of chance
in these mechanics the player is always
guaranteed to receive in-game content
even if the player unfortunately
receives something they don't want
yay have responded to the news of the
Belgian investigation with a statement
that highlights that the in-game loot
boxes always guarantee usable in-game
content and that players can earn crates
through playing and not spending
real-world money we'll be sure to keep
you updated on how this one shakes out
so make sure you keep tuning in that's
everything we have for you today enjoy
the rest of your day and don't forget to
join us tomorrow we're gonna break down
three of the biggest stories of the
entire week yes and on top of that we'll
also be back for a 72 hours stream this
weekend of which we will be doing the
last 24 hours so remember to join us for
that we're kicking off at midday PT time
on Friday and it's gonna be starting in
the US and then it's gonna be 36 hours
in the u.s. 12 hours in the UK office
and then 24 hours right here in
Australia for extra life 2017 so please
tune in see you guys there maybe it's
not long now until you can kick the [ __ ]
out of Fraser and dragon ball fly to Z
well flight is whatever the hell it's
gold to have a companion called fridge
good one thank you do you want to tell
the rest of the story part of the intro
we'll just leave it at that
okay what does we know there is three
new characters have been nouns